[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض نبداها كالمعتاد
روسيات تعلن تدمير مركز للعمليات تديره
دول غربيه في ليفيف تجدد التاكيد افق
التسويه بعيد
حريصه ايضا
بشكل كبير على
دعم كل ما من شانه رفض سعودي في كييف وزير
الخارجيه يجدد نهج السعوديه لحل الازمه
السياسيه انه انسانيا
ابره مونجارو تدخل سوق السعوديه علاج فعال
للسكري والتساؤلات حول اعراضها وعلاقتها
بالسمنه
في الرابعه
300 محامي سعودي ينضمون لمبادره المحامي
المجاني خدمه تطوعيه لمستفيدي الضمان
الاجتماعي
وللمره الاولى وزاره الحج والعمره
السعوديه تقيم دورات تدريبيه لتهيئه
الحجاج في بلدانهم
نبدا من تطورات الحرب في اوكرانيا حيث
اكدت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه استمرار تكميد
القوات الاوكرانيه خسائر في محاور
دانياتسك وكوبيانسك
وقال المتحدث باسم الوزاره في البيان
اليومي ان القوات الروسيه تدمرت مركزا
للاستخبارات الالكترونيه تابعا للجيش
الاوكراني في مقاطعه كما دمرت مستودع
ذخيره تابعه للقوات الاوكرانيه في مقاطعه
ومركزا اخر للعمليات الخاصه تديره دول
غربيه في ليبيف غربيه البلاد
من جهه اخرى كشف وزير دفاع بولندا ماريوش
بلاشك
بدات تزويد اوكرانيا بذخائر قبل بدء
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه وقال بلاشاك في
مقابله مع صحيفه بولنديه ان اولى شحنات
الذخيره ارسلت الى اوكرانيا قبل الحرب كما
اشار الى ان هذا ادى الى تسارع العمل
المتعلق بتجهيز الجيش الاوكراني واضاف
وزير الدفاع بولندا قريب سنزودك بدبابات
وعلى صعيد جهود التسويه ذكرت صحيفه بيلد
الالمانيه نقلا عن مصادر في الحكومتين
الالمانيات والامريكيه ان الغرب سيضغط على
اجبارها على اجراء محادثات سلام مع موسكو
اذا فشلت القوات الاوكرانيه في تحقيق تقدم
كبير بحلول الخريف ذكرت الصحيفه ان
المسؤولين الامريكيين والاوروبيين يريدون
منح اوكرانيا فرصه لاستعاده المزيد من
الاراضي بحلول الخريف وشن المزيد من الهزم
من الهجمات المضاده قبل التفاوض مع روسيا
اذا فشلت اوكرانيا وقالت صحيفه ان الغرب
يقدم وعودا بدعم لاوكرانيا الى ما لا
نهايه لكن من وراء الكواليس هناك حديث
بالفعل عما وصفته بانذار عسكري لفلاديمير
زينينسكي
من جهاتها شددت رئاسه روسيه الكرملين بان
عوده شبه جزيره القرم الى اوكرانيا يعد
امرا مستحيلا وانها باتت جزءا لا يتجزا من
روسيا وقال المتحدث باسم الرئاسه الروسيه
ان الظروف غير متوافره لانهاء النزاع في
اوكرانيا سلميا في الوقت الراهن كما اشار
ايضا الى ان روسيا ستدرس خطه السلام
الصينيه وتحلل تفاصيلها بشكل دقيق ولن
تقبل باي شروط مسبقه للمفاوضات
وبعد ايام من الذكرى الاولى للحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه وفد سعودي برئاسه وزير
الخارجيه العاصمه الاوكرانيه كييف دلالات
كبيره حملتها الزياره السياسيه وانسانيات
تؤكد على موقف السعوديه من الازمه وجهودها
لخفض التصعيد
سعودي في كييف تاكيد على قدره الرياض على
الحفاظ على علاقاتها مع طرفي الحرب علاقه
مساعده لاوكرانيا وعمل سياسي ودبلوماسي مع
روسيا خلال الزياره التقى وزير الخارجيه
السعودي الامير فيصل بن فرحان بالرئيس
الاوكراني
في جلسه مباحثات جمعت الوفدين نتج عنها
اتمام حزمه المساعدات التي تعهد بها ولي
العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان
للرئيس الاوكراني قبل اشهر قليله
وتشمل الحزمه مساعدات انسانيه اضافيه
لاوكرانيا بقيمه تصل الى 400 مليون دولار
منها 100 مليون دولار لتنفيذ برنامج سعودي
اوكراني مشترك بين مركز الملك سلمان
للاغاثه والاعمال الانسانيه ووزاره تنميه
المجتمعات والاقاليم في اوكرانيا فيما
تضمنت الاتفاقيه تقديم مليون دولار على
شكل منحه مشتقات نفطيه جرى توقيعها بين
الصندوق السعودي للتنميه ووزاره الطاقه
الاوكرانيه
الامير فيصل بن فرحان جدد خلال الزياره
دعم السعوديه لجميع الجهود الدوليه
الراميه لحل الازمه الاوكرانيه الروسيه
سياسيا ومواصله جهودها للاسهام في تخفيف
الاثار الانسانيه الناجمه عنها المملكه
حريصه ايضا
بشكل كبير على
دعم كل ما من شانه الاسهام في خفض حده
التوتر والتصعيد والوصول الى حل سلمي لهذه
الحرب دور سعودي لما يقتصر على الجانب
السياسي او حتى الانساني في الداخل
الاوكراني بل شمل ايضا المقيمين
الاوكرانيين على الاراضي السعوديه عبر
منحهم تسهيلات خاصه لحين انتهاء الازمه في
بلادهم جهود وساطه
تبذلها الرياض في ازمه اوكرانيا بدات
بالافراج عن عشره اسرى من 50 جنسيات ولن
تنتهي بزياره الامس التاريخيه الى
انضم الينافر الاستوديو عبد العزيز بن صقر
رئيس مركز الخليج حياك الله دكتور اولا
بالنظر الى توقيت الزياره وظروف الحرب
اليوم والتصريحات حول عدم قبول اي طرف باي
نهج سلمي
وطبيعه وحجم المساعدات التي قدمتها
السعوديه لاوكرانيا هل تغير السعوديه
موقفها من الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
اولا مساء الخير استاذ خالد المشاهدين
العربيه في كل مكان في الحقيقه هذا
استمرار لموقف المملكه من البدايه وهو
انها ترفض الاحتلال بقوه او استخدام العنف
هي تؤكد على وحده الاراضي الاوكرانيه هي
لا تقبل الاقرشيبا او ما يسمى باستخدام
القوه العسكريه الاحتلال يعني اي جزء من
هذا هي تتفهم الدوافع الروسيه فيما يتعلق
بانها
القومي المهم في هذا الجانب هي ايضا
قامت بدور وساطه في يعني مثل ما ذكر
تقريركم بالنسبه لبعض السجناء اللي كانوا
موجودين الاسرى في ذلك الوقت وكان هذا جاد
بطلب من الحكومه البريطانيه على فكره في
الاساس والمملكه استجابت واستطاعت بفضل
اسمه دور ولي العهد في هذا الجانب باطلاق
سراح هؤلاء الاسرار هذه المواقف كلها كانت
تعتبر ضمن الموقف المحايد لانها صوتت
الامم المتحده صوتت في مجلس التعاون دول
الخليج العربي ضد استخدام العنف وضد هذا
الموقف المتوازن ياتي كيف ياتي في قضيتين
مهمه ياتي في انه
ليس بالضروره نقطع علاقتي مع روسيا وليس
بالضروره ان اقف مع المعسكر المعادي
لروسيا في هذا الجانب انا لي مصالحي ولي
علاقاتي انا ناديت من اليوم الاول باللجوء
الى الحل الطرق السياسيه والدبلوماسيه لحل
هذه الازمه انا ضد استخدام العنف او
الوسيله وارى انه البعد الانساني مهم
ولذلك المساهمه الانسانيه اللي قدمتها
المملكه 400 مليون دولار موزعه 100 مليون
دولار بشكل مساعدات انسانيه
هي تاكيد على موقف المملكه للدعم الانساني
والسياسي في هذا الجانب فهو انت هو هو
بالتاكيد وقوف مع
الطرف المتضرر وهو وهي اوكرانيا في هذا
الجانب ولذلك يعني هذه الزياره مهمه طبعا
انا احيي شجاعه سمو الامير فيصل انه راح
بالقطار وتعنى هو ولفظ المرافق معه سواء
معالي الدكتور الربيعه او المدير الصندوق
السعودي اللي ذهبوا معه هؤلاء جميعا ذهبوا
موقف خادم الحرمين الشريفين موقف سمو
للعهد والحكومه السعوديه في انها تراعي
الجوانب الانسانيه ترى اهميتها تقف يعني
في الازمات الموقف الذي يجب هل هذا يعني
انه هذا الموقف هذه الزياره جاءت بالتنسيق
مع الطرف الروسي وكذلك مع الطرف الغربي
دكتور عبد العزيز ليس بالضروره انها جاءت
بالتنسيق او ليست بالضروره ان تحسب انها
يعني استجابه لمطالب غربيه وانما هي
استمرار للنهج السعودي من اول يوم على
فكره هنالك اساءه فهم الموقف السعودي الكل
اعتبر ان اسرار المملكه على موضوع اوبيك
بلس هو انحياز لجانب روسيا وهذا غير صحيح
اثبتت الدلائل بان المملكه بموقفها في
الاوبك بلس حافظت على اسعار النفط حافظت
على الاسواق والتوازنها ولم يكن موقفا
منحزن روسيا لما رات مصلحتها ان تبيع
باسعار منخفضه الى الهند والى الصين بناقص
اكثر من 30% من الاسعار العالميه خدمت
مصلحتها في هذا الجانب وباعت بهذا لكن
الغرب حينما راى انه يؤكد على يعني
تحجيم الدور الروسي اقتصاديا عسكريا
سياسيا اوقف الاستيراد من روسيا واخذ موقف
واضح في هذا وبدا يبحث عن بدائل حتى وان
كان كلفه الكثير والكثير منه دكتور لكن
الغرب له موقف اخر وخاصه الامريكيين يمكن
في ميونخ التي جئتها يعني
امس تقريبا كان لك سؤال طرحته على وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي في هذا الخصوص حول موقف
دول الخليج من الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
كان وزير الخارجي واضحا في رده
لا توازن في هذه الحرب او لا موقف متوازن
في هذه الحرب بما ان تكون معنا بمعنى من
تكون معنا او ضدنا فبالتالي الى اي مدى
يعني السعوديه وكذلك دول الخليج وغيرها من
الدول في المنطقه هي قادره على البقاء في
هذا الموقع موقع التوازن او عدم الانحياز
خاصه نحن نتحدث عن تصاعد في العمليات
العسكريه
وامداد غربي كبير بكل انواع الاسلحه
والتقارير تتحدث يعني عن
مرحله اخرى ستدخل فيها الحرب الربيع
المقبل يعني دكتور ما رايك فيها صحيح انا
يعني في السؤال الوزير الخارجيه حاولت ان
اشرح الموقف الخليجي واساله انه شو موقفه
هو من هذا الموقف المتوازن مثل ما هم
قبلوه للهند وقبلوه لتركيا وقبلوه
لاسرائيل لماذا لا يقبل لدول الخليج هذا
الموقف وهو كان جوابه واضح انه
لا يوجد توازن حينما يوجد استخدام العنف
في هذا الجانب ويكون في طرف متضرر اتفهم
الموقف الامريكي لان الموقف الامريكي قائم
هو والغربي قائم على فرضيه واحده انه لا
يمكن السماح بانتصار روسيا ولا يمكن
السماح عسكريين ولا يمكن السماح بتغيير
خارطه الجغرافيا السياسيه في تلك المنطقه
هذا الموقف الامريكي الواضح ولذلك هو لا
يريد اي مواقف متوازنه هو يريد هزيمه
كامله مع انه هذا احد السيناريوهات
المتوقعه في مستقبل متعدده هذا احداها وهو
الهزيمه الكامله لكذا السيناريو الاخر هو
ان يحقق الروس انتصار فيصير هناك تفاوض
يعني سواء باستخدام القوه العسكريه
المفرطه المباغته عمل يعني خارج عن الاطار
المتداول والمالوف فتحقق فايضا هذا
السيناريو اخر سيناريو ثلاث استمرار الوضع
كما هو وقف اطلاق النار ولكن لا يوجد حل
سياسي وهذا ممكن ان يستمر فتره مثلا اطول
القرم شبه جزيره القرم لا احد يتحدث عنها
من الغربيين فربما يكون هنالك سيناريو اخر
تخفيض المساحه التي استولت عليها روسيا
يعني بدلا من ان تكون 20% من الاراضي
الاوكرانيه عشره في المئه او جزء منها
يقبل حتى يكون مخرج سياسي مقبول فيقبل
الطرفين بهذه
المساومه السيناريوهات المتعدده كلها
انا في قناعتي ما زال مبكر انه نشوف نتائج
لانه امريكا قررت ان تزيد حجم الدعم
العسكري الى 50
من الخبراء والمحللين وهو ان
يتحول هذا الصراع الى صراع طويل الامد بين
بين روسيا واوكرانيا والغرب بشكل كبير
يعني اليوم اليوم يعني قرروا مبلغ بسيط في
البدايه 140 مليار دولار تقريبا في اعاده
الاعمار في اوكرانيا من اين سوف ياتي هذا
المبلغ سوف ياتي من المبالغ الروسيه التي
تم الحجز عليها في عاده الاعمار في
اوكرانيا فهنا ايضا يعني هزيمه سياسيه من
ناحيه هزيمه اقتصاديه لم تقبل بهزيمتها في
اوكرانيا ومستعده لاستخدام كل انواع
الاسلحه حتى
لم نتطرق له وهو وقف اطلاق النار
والانسحاب وليس هزيمه يعني هذا ايضا خيار
روسي ممكن ان يكون اليوم يوقف اطلاق النار
ويسحب قواته فهذا انسحاب وليس هزيمه هذه
الدول قادره على التعامل مع هذه
الفيديوهات والبقاء في ذات المنطقه امان
الامر سيختلف على قناعتي انه الغربيين
يرون ان هنالك دول بلطيق امام مخاطره
اسبانيا الدول هذه ايضا هي امام يعني خطر
روسي كبير الخوف انه لو نجحت روسيا في في
اوكرانيا ان تتمدد وان تعود الى مناطق الى
مولدوفيا الى الى هذه المناطق وتحاول ان
تعيد بسط النفود لان الكل او الغربيين
يتحدثون لا امبراطوريه روسيه بدون
اوكرانيا
فهذه ايضا سيناريو اخر يطرح نفسه في هذا
الجانب لكن الموقف الواضح اليوم ان هنالك
التزام غربي اكيد
بدعم اوكرانيا بعدم السماح لروسيا بتحقيق
اي انتصار عسكري هنالك هزائم كبيره
الحقيقه في الجانبين من ناحيه البشريه او
من ناحيه العداد العسكري التجهيزات
الجديده التي منحت لاوكرانيا بما فيها
الدبابات الالمانيه هي جزء دفاع هي موجه
لمناطق تريد ان تزيل الاحتلال عنها
وتحررها فهذا ايضا يطرح نفسه بشكل شكرا
جزيلا لك دكتور عبد العزيز بن صقر الرئيس
مركز الخليج شكرا لك
رابعه مستمر فيها بعد قليل ابره مونجارو
تدخل سوق السعوديه علاج فعال للسكري
والتساؤلات حول اعراضها وعلاقتها بسهوله
اهلا بكم من جديد شهدت الرياض اقامه اول
ملتقى للاستثمار في اداره النفايات في
السعوديه بمشاركته 300 مستثمر من داخل
وخارج السعوديه في سعين لجلب الاستثمارات
في قطاع يتوقع ان يساهم باكثر من عشره
مليارات ريال من الناتج المحلي بحلول 2035
عبد المحسن الحربي
من عبء اقتصادي الى فرص استثماريه واعده
هكذا يتم طرح عدد كبير من الفرص في
استثمار في الاستثمار في قطاع اداره
النفايات من خلال المركز الوطني لاداره
النفايات وبمشاركه واسعه تحدث عن ما يقارب
300 مستثمر محلي ودولي بالاضافه الى خبراء
من مختلف انحاء العالم يشاركون في هذا
الملتقى الاول من نوعه بعد ان كان هنالك
توجه سعودي خلال سنوات الماضيه في
الاستثمار في هذا القطاع بعد ان كانت نسب
اعاده التدوير لا تتخطى 5% هنالك ايضا فرص
كبيره من قبل الجهات السعوديه المختلفه
لتعظيم هذا الرقم وكذلك اداره
النفايات من خلال عدد من الشركات ومن خلال
التشريعات التي تم طرحها خلال الفتره
الماضيه او الاستراتيجيات التي من المتوقع
تساهم في حزمه فرص استثماريه تقدر ب80
مليار ريال سعودي الحقيقه بعد ما تم وضع
اطار مؤسسي جديد لهذا القطاع وايضا اطار
التشريعي بدات مرحله التخطيط وعمل ماستر
بلان لاداره النفايات في المملكه هذا
الماستر بلان نوزع مساحه المملكه الى 25
مجموعه جغرافيه كل مجموعه تكون مكتفيه
بالنفايده التي تنتج بها وبها البنيه
التحتيه المطلوبه والملائمه للاستفاده من
النفايات المنتجه داخل هذه المجموعه اليوم
اطلقنا
المخرجات اولى المجموعات الجغرافيه وهي
مجموعه منطقه الرياض انتهاء عصر المرادم
وانبعاثاتها الكربونيه الضاره في مختلف
مدن السعوديه وعدد من مواضيع الاخرى التي
تم طرحها في ملتقى الاستثمار في اداره
النفايات بمشاركه واسعه بالاضافه الى
الحديث عن التشريعات التي تشغل من عمل
مستثمر في سواء كان المستثمر المحلي او
الخارجي ليضخ الاستثمارات في مختلف
المصانع لاعاده التدوير وايضا لانتاج هذه
النفايات مجددا بالاضافه الى انتاج الطاقه
وعدد من الموارد الاخرى التي ستتوفر جراء
اعاده التدوير والاستفاده من اداره
النفايات بالاضافه الى الهدف الكبير وهو
توفير 77 الف فرصه عمل من خلال هذه
الاستراتيجيات التي تم اطلاقها وايضا
الوصول الى المساهمه بالناتج المحلي
الاجمالي للسعوديه
ب120 مليار ريال سعودي بحلول عام 20/5
وثلاثين عبد المحسن الحربي العربيه الرياض
علاج جديد للسكري يدخل السعوديه بعد
اعتمادها هيئه الغذاء والدواء لابره
مونجارو او ما يعرف بترز
كعلاج فعال السكري من النوع الثاني يعملوا
هذا العلاج على خفض معدل السكر التراكمي
وبدوره يؤدي الى حمايه القلب والكل وفقا
لاطباء تعد الاعراض الجانبيه للعلاج
الجديد اقل من تلك المصاحبه لابره
الاوزمبيك الشهيره ويعمل العلاج على
المساعده في نزول الوزن من خلال تقليل
الشهيه وزياده الشعور بالشبع لكنه ليس
مخصصا لانزال الوزن وفق تاكيدات هيئه
الغذاء والدواء تصل نسبه نزول الوزن الى
نحو 22 ونصف بالمئه عند اخذ الجرعه
بمقدارها الاعلى
في استديوهاتنا من الرياض ينضم لنا
الدكتور عاصم القرشي استشاري امراض السكري
حياك الله دكتور حياك الله الاستاذ خالد
النطق اول شيء هي ابره مونجارو منجاره
ممتاز خلينا ناخذ فكره وعرفنا على هذه
الابره هل هي لعلاج السكري ولا لعلاج
السمنه او لهما جميعا يعني نبغى ناخذ فكره
عنها عباره عن علاج للسكري يؤخذ مره واحده
في الاسبوع عباره عن ابرات وخد تحت الجلد
الجدير فيها ان الجديد فيها انها عباره عن
هرمونين اللي هو كان مستخدم سابقا في
الاوزومبيك
والفكتوز سابقا والان بدا اضافه له
الهرمون الجيئه وهو الثوره الان في هذا
العلاج
النتائج لهذا العلاج المنجاره اثبتت
انخفاض في معدل السكر التراكمي لمرضى
السكري وايضا نزول كبير في الوزن العلاج
الان في نهايه الغذاء والدواء السعوديه
كعلاج للسكري في خفض الوزن في خفض السكري
من من مرضى السكري يمكن ان يستخدمه
ويستفيد منه مرضى السكري بشكل عام ينقسمون
الى النوع الاول والنوع الثاني غير
الانواع الاخرى فهو مخصص للنوع الثاني من
السكري دائما اللي يعانون من زياده في
الوزن فهو فعال لهم اول شيء ينزل الوزن
ثاني شيء يقلل من شهيتهم للاكل وبذلك ينقص
السكر التراكمي بشكل فعال فهو ينقص السكر
التراكمي بنسبه اثنين فاصله ثلاثه في
المئه كاحد اقصى في اعلى جرعاته يعني
معناته هذا بس للناس اللي عندهم ارتفاع في
مستوى السكر اللي عندهم هبوط الناس اللي
عندهم هبوط
ما يحتاج يحتاج علاج ونعرف سبب الهبوط
تسد الشهيه تماما وتضعف والشهيه هيا تضعف
الشهيه لدرجه انه مراحل ان الواحد يقول ما
ما يحب ياكل خاصه في بدايته ولذلك هي تؤخذ
على تدريجي
السكر راح من المريض واذا هو لا زال على
العلاج اذا قطع العلاج راح يرجع السكر
فنقول انه المريض الازال عنده سكر بما انه
هو العلاج في ناس بعض الاطباء تكلموا عن
اعراض جانبيه يعني وحذروا منها يمكن انت
قرات بعض الاطباء يتكلموا عن هذا الموضوع
في وسائل التواصل ثوره كبيره
انه تصيب بالام في المعده انه انه تسد
الشهيه تماما يتحدث عن مشاكل قد تصل او
تتسبب في اورام بالبنكرياس او في الغده
الدرقيه وحتى انه هيئه الغذاء والدواء
الامريكيه في في في النشره المربع الاسود
وضعت تحذير عالي الخطوره
لهذا هذه
طبعا هذه هذه المضاعفات ليست تريده اللحظه
في هذه العلاج للمنجار ولكن هي من مصاحبه
من بدايه الفكتوزا جي ال بي ون ثوره ثوره
الجيل بي 1 ودخولها الى الاسواق
وجدوا في التجارب ان المرضى الذين لديهم
اورام في الغده الدرقيه مدلل لثيروت
كارسنوم هم معرضين انه لهذه الموجود عندهم
او موجود عندهم تاريخ مرضي لهذه الاورام
تزيد نسبه الاصابه كما هي ايضا تسبب
بنسبه بسيطه
التهاب في البنكرياس لان لان
مستقبلاتها هي في خلايا خلايا البنكرياس
ما هي الطريقه الامثل للاستخدام هذه
الابرد هي عباره تؤخذ مره اسبوعين ولازم
تاخذ تحت استشاره الطبيب لابد من استشاره
ايوه
الان بعد التنظيمات وزاره الصحه وهيئه
الغذاء والدواء اصلا المواطن لا يستطيع ان
ياخذها بدون وصفه طبيه فالوصفه الطبيه
ضروريه وهي وهي مصرحه لمرضى السكر النوع
الثاني فقط وليست مصرحه في السعوديه لمرضى
السمنه هو انا اخذها بس ولا لابد اقوم
بنشاط ثاني في المقابل يعني
حتى استفيد من من نادي الجراح علاج السكر
علاج السكر بدايه نقول المريض اول شيء
نبدا بالحميه وبالنشاط الرياضي وتغيير
السلوك الحياه لسلوك صحي وبعد كذا نبدا
العلاج منظم السكر وبعدين نبدا علاجات
تكون
امتنع عن الاكل او الطعام يقلل
وجبات خفيفه
في ساعات معينه يعني ايش الافضل
كيف تشتغل هي تتحفز من افراز الانسولين
تقلل من افراز السكر تقلل من من عمليه
الهضم وهذا ما يقلل من السكر بعد الوجبات
وهي ايضا
تلعب في مركز الدماغ في تقليل الشهيه
فلذلك الانسان يشعر بضعف الشهيه وما ياكل
يسبب ممكن الم في المعده اللي هي مساله
انه ما ياكل مثلا
من قائمه الانترنت هي تلعب في هرمونات
الهضمتي هو تقليل تقليل خروج الطعام من من
المعده الى الامعاء بعض الدكاتره تحدثوا
عن لابد ايضا بالتوازي من شرب المياه
بكثره صحيح
صحيحته فينسى يشرب المياه فنقول للمريض
دائما اشرب مويه بكثره عشان ما تتوفر عندك
ما تصير لك مشاكل من جفاف في المياه تنصح
دكتور المرضى اللي يجون عندك باستخدام هذه
الابره هي طبعا ثوره في عالم السكري الناس
اللي ما عندهم مضاعفات واللي نسمح نعطيهم
اللي ما نسمح نعطيهم هم سكر النوع الاول
فننتبه ان سكر النوع الاول والحوامل
الاطفال اقل من 18 سنه الناس اللي عندهم
تاريخ مره اكثر من 65 سنه لانه التجارب
عليهم التجارب فانصح فيها بانها ثوره في
العلاج ولكن انصح فيها بشكل تدريجي وان
شاء الله باذن الله تنزل السعوديه قريب
لا هي اعلى من الاذن
حتى في اعلى جرعاتها الوقافي تنزل حتى 15%
الترابزيت هاي تنزل حتى 22
في موقعيه الغذاء والدواء 1261 ريال ولكن
مقارنه بدول الخليج بدور الخليج ينباع ب
1730 ريال فانا اشوف انه سعره في السعوديه
مقارنه بغير وافضل ولكن بشكل عام هو سعره
اغلى من الاوزون 380 ريال فلذلك ولكن
كفائده وكثوره في في نعلم السكري انا
اشوفه علاج جدا ممتاز واللي موسمين وعنده
سكر اثنين يعني هذا احنا دائما في في
السعوديه نتبع ما تقول هيئه الغذاء
والدواء السعوديه فهيئه الغذاء والدواء
صرحت له فقط لمرضى السكري شكرا لك دكتور
عاصم القرشي شكرا جزيلا
الرابعه ايضا مستمره فيها بعد قليل ناس
تعلن تاجيل اطلاق مهمه كروي سته الى
الفضاء حتى يشعرني اخر وعلامتها الاماراتي
السلطان النياتي
تدمير مركز للعمليات تدير دول غربيه في
وتجدد التاكيد افوق التسويه بعيد
او المملكه حريصه ايضا
بشكل كبير على
كيف وزير الخارجيه يجدد نهج السعوديه لحل
الازمه السياسيا وانسانيا
ابره مونجارو تدخل السوق السعوديه علاج
فعال للسكري والتساؤلات حول اعراضها
وعلاقتها بالسمنه
و 300 محامي سعودي ينضمون لمبادره المحامي
المجاني خدمه تطوعيه لمستفيدي الضمان
الاجتماعي
للمره الاولى وزاره الحج والعمره السعوديه
تقيم دورات تدريبيه لتهيئه الحجاج في
بلدانهم
اهلا بكم من جديد محامي مجاني مبادره
تطوعيه جديده في السعوديه للمستفيدين من
الضمان الاجتماعي اكثر من 300 محامي
سعوديين انضموا للمبادره التي اعلنت عنها
الهيئه السعوديه للمحامين تستهدف المرافع
بشكل مجاني مستفيديا ضمان الاجتماعي غير
القادرين على التحمل التكاليف الماليه
لتوكيل المحامي
محامي دون اتعاب مبادره جديده كشفت عنها
الهيئه السعوديه للمحامين تتضمن توكيل
محامي لكل مستفيد من الضمان الاجتماعي
يصعب عليه دفع الاتعاب في مرافعاته
القضائيه هناك عدد من
المندرجين في طلبات الحصول على المعونه
القضائيه
من قبل هي السعوديه للمحامين وايضا
يتم ايصال هذه المحامين
الراغبين في تقديم هذه المعونه القضائيه
للمستحقين
المامول من هذه الاتفاقيه باذن الله تعالى
انها ترفع مستوى
التعاون ما بين الجانبيه بحيث انه تصل
لاكبر شريحه ممكنه من المستحقين المبادره
اطلقت قبل ايام وانضم اليها اكثر من 300
محام سعودي ابدوا استعدادهم للترافع عن
المسجدين في الضمان الاجتماعي بالتع مع
وزاره الموارد البشريه والتنميه
الاجتماعيه التي عملت على تطوير منصه
الكترونيه لاستقبال الطلبات مع جهود اخرى
لاعلام مستفيدي الضمان عبر فروع الوزاره
بالمدن والقرى السعوديه
الغرض انه كثير من المحامين يعبر دائما عن
رغبتهم في الدعم
المجتمع من خلال تقديم ساعات عمل مجانيه
او الترافع بشكل مجاني
واعتقد الجهه الامثل التي تقدم لهذه
الساعات التطوعيه ويترافع بشكل مجاني
اخواننا وزملائنا ومن المستحقين
الضمان الاجتماعي خدمه المحامي المجاني
تعبر عن الدور الاجتماعي الذي يقدمه
المحامون المتطوعون وتعد من ابرز
التحديثات التي يشهدها القطاع العدلي في
السعوديه بين عام اخر من الرياض نواف عزيز
العربيه
انضم الينا المتحدث باسم وزاره الموارد
البشريه والتنميه الاجتماعيه ساعه الحماد
حياك الله سعد سعيد
يعني اخذ منك بعض المعلومات حول هذه
المبادره يعني من اللي من يستفيد منها
وكيف يتم ذلك
حياك الله اخوي خالد وحيا الله كافه
السيدات والساده المشاهدين والمستمعين
الكرام طبعا هذه الخدمه باختصار شديد هي
مقدمه لمستفيدين الضمان الاجتماعي اللي لا
يتمكنون او لا يستطيعون من دفع اتعاب
المحاماه للاستعانه بمحامي امام مختلف
كافه الجهات القضائيه وبالتالي نعمل على
دعم هؤلاء المستفيدين وفق استراتيجيه
مدروسه لضمان حياه كريمه لهم وتحقق
استقرار هؤلاء المستفيدين وايضا بالتعاون
مع الهيئه السعوديه للمحامين نقوم برفع
مستوى ممارسه المحامين لمهنتهم وضمان حسن
ادائهم فيما يقدمونه لكافه
مستفيدين وكافه ايضا الجوانب الخاصه
بالقضاء الخدمات طبعا المقدمه نتكلم اليوم
عن استشارات فيما يخص فيما يخص الجوانب
القضائيه ونتحدث عن ايضا المساعده في
اعداد
الصياغه او الخاصه باللوائح القانونيه
والترافع امام الجهات القضائيه طبعا
المستفيدين هم كافه للمستفيدين الضمان
الاجتماعي بدون تحديد فئات معينه او تحديد
يعني مستويات معينه من ناحيه المستفيدين
من الضمان الاجتماعي بس هم هذه المبادره
والمنصه فقط للمستفيدين الضمان الاجتماعي
طبعا خليني بس اذكر نقطه مهمه هي ليست
منصه حديثه اللحظه هي خدمه موجوده على
الهيئه السعوديه للمحامين وهي خدمه
المعونه القضائيه ولكن اليوم حنا من خلال
توقيع هذه الاتفاقيه تم اطلاق باسم خدمه
المعونه القضائيه المستفيدين الضمان
الاجتماعي ولا اصلا الخدمه هي موجوده
بالسابق لكافه المواطنين في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه اليوم حنا نتكلم عن انه
المستفيد من الضمان الاجتماعي بامكان
الدخول على هذه الخدمه من خلال تسجيله في
الموقع وبعد ذلك يضع الجوانب التي تتعلق
بطلب المحامي وايضا يقوم تاكيد لانه
مستفيدين من الضمان الاجتماعي يرفق مشهد
ضمان اجتماعي في خانه تحميل او تعريف
الراتب وبعد ذلك يكمل باقي التسجيل هنا
يتم اعفاء المستفيد الضمان الضمان
الاجتماعي من مساله اتعاب المحامي وايضا
هناك امتداد سابق لقرار سامي باعفاء
مستفيدين الضمان الاجتماعي من ناحيه
تكاليف الاحكام القضائيه ونقصد في ذلك
الجوانب التي اقرت اقرت على مرافعات
وتحصلها الجهه المعنيه في هذا الامر
فاليوم الوزاره تعمل على كافه الجوانب
التي تتعلق بالجوانب في كل القضايا ساعد
ولا في قضايا معينه في كافه الجوانب نتكلم
عن استشارات قانونيه في قضايا الطلاق
والحضانه والنفقه وايضا نتكلم عن جوانب
خاصه بالاحوال الشخصيه نتكلم عن جوانب
خاصه ايضا متابعه الجوانب العماليه وايضا
متابعه حال المستفيدين وغيره من الجوانب
المتعلقه طبعا هناك عده مساله طيب الخطوات
اللي تتم ما يسجل في المنصه ويرفق المشهد
وغيرها من الامور وش الخطوات التاليه بعد
ذلك عارضه مباشره يتم تواصل المحامي
المعني المتطوع في هذا الامر وبالتالي
يقوم بدراسه حاله حيثيه المستفيد من
الضمان الاجتماعي وقم بالترافع عن الحاله
مباشره عندنا عده مسارات في هذا الموضوع
مسارين المسار الاول كيف يتم التقديم خاصه
من اشخاص كبار في السن او اشخاص ذوي
الاعاقه لا يستطيعون الوصولون او الوصول
الى هذه الخدمه هنا لدينا عيادات التمكين
الموجوده في كافه مناطق المملكه بامكان
كبير السن او الاشخاص ذوي الاعاقه زياره
هذه الحضانه وبالتالي شرح او العياده شرح
الموضوع وشرح حيثياته ويقومون به تقديم
مسار سريع له وخدمته بشكل مطلوب ايضا
لدينا مسار خاص
بالباحث الاجتماعي الذي يقوم بزياره
المستفيدين من الضمان في منازلهم والتاكد
من حالتهم الصحيه وحالتهم الاجتماعيه وغير
من الجوانب وفي حال شعر بانه يحتاج الى
محاوله محامي يقوم بالتقديم بالمسار
السريع
لهذا المستفيد من الضمان الاجتماعي خدمناه
بشكل سريع هنا وايضا مستفيده اخرين
بامكانهم الدخول على الخدمه بشكل مباشر
وطلب كافه التفاصيل المهنيه في هذا عندكم
احصائيه وارقام بعدد الاستفاده من هذه
المبادره والمنصه حتى الان ولا يعني
مبدئيا ولله الحمد حتى الان يعني من خلال
هذه الاتفاقيه استفد اكثر من 500 شخص وهذا
امر يؤكد على اهميه مثل هذه الاتفاقيات
التي عملت عليها الوزاره سواء مع الهيئه
السعوديه للمحامين او سواء مع القطاع
الخاص او سواء مع القطاع غير ربحي في
الجوانب القانونيه او الاجتماعيه او
التعليم
تماما ولا رمزي
لا مجاني لا محامي هو متطوع صحيح طيب انا
نشكرك وبالتالي بعدها يكون هذا المحامي
ملتزم معه في المرافعه وفي القضايا وفي
غيرها من الامور ولا فقط يقتصر دوره على
تقديم الاستشاره لا يتصل دوره في
مطالبه حقوق المستفيد وغيرها من الجوانب
المتعلقه بالاستشارات الفنيه وغيرها من
الصياغه وغيرها جزاهم الله خير المحامين
المتطوعين وان شاء الله نقرا يعني كمان
عدد اكبر من العدد الحالي الذي ينضموا لها
المبادره شكرا جزيلا لك حماد متحدث باسم
وزاره الموارد البشريه والتنميه
الاجتماعيه
في ماليزيا قامت وزاره الحج والعمره
السعوديه دوره تدريبيه تعنى بالتدريب قائد
مجموعات الحجاج من بلد الحاج قبل القدوم
الى السعوديه الدوره تعد الاولى من نوعها
تشمل شرحا مفصلا لرحله الحج من بدايه
مغادرته بلاده مرورا بكافه المرافق قبل
واثناء وبعد تاديه نسك الحج والمهارات
الحياتيه اثناء اداء النسخ تهدف الى تاهيل
قائد مجموعات الحجاج في بلادهم فضلا عن
تحقيق التكامل لمواكبه التطور لخدمات ضيوف
الرحمن ورفع الكفاءه كفاءه الكوادر
البشريه العامله في موسم الحج
قبل لحظات من اطلاقها الى محطه الفضاء
الدوليه اجلت وكاله الفضائل الامريكيه ناس
اطلاق مهمه سته التي ياتي على متنها رائد
الفضائل الاماراتيه سلطان النيادي الى وقت
اخر المهمه تعد اول مهمه طويله الامد لاي
رائد من رواد الفضاء العرب وثاني مهمه
اماراتيه الى محطه الفضاء الدوليه
اللاجئين السوريين بعد الزلزال لا تنتهي
بعض العائلات رغم مرور ثلاثه اسابيع على
وقوع الزلزال جل امانيهم الحصول على خيمه
تقيهم بروده الطقس زيدان زنك
قبل زلزال كان هذا المقهى وسط السوق
التاريخي في كهرمان مرعش مقصدا للزوار
لكنه اليوم بات ملاذا اخيرا لعائلات سوريه
لاجئه تقطعت بها السبل والامال بعدما دمرت
منازلها في زلزال وباتت اليوم بلا ماوى
مطلبها الوحيد خيمه
المشكله انه زلمه تركي الله يكثر خيره
وعطونا هالخيمه هي قهوه بركنا فيها الزلمه
بده يشتغل بده يشتغل زلم بدنا شيدر طالبين
من اهل الخير شيدر انه نبرك نحن 18 شخص
وعنا اثنين عجز في دين امهم البيت انخرف
هون وفي ايدين امهم وابوهم عاجز لانه
طالبين قصر ولنا طيبين مملكه طيبين خيم
شوادر بس انه انت فيها 18 يوم والله
العظيم تحت المطر والبرد الارض من تحتهم
ما زالت تواصل اهتزازها وامطار تهطل من
السماء فوقهم تضيق الدنيا عليهم ومعها
امال صمود الاطفال امام رخاوه الارض وغضب
الشتاء الاولاد لا في صوبه لا في تدفئه لا
في مي انه يشربن طيب منين نروح نحن نجيب
نحن هيك امر الله وصار فينا مثل الاهوال
يوم القيامه نحن ثلاث عيلات
وعندي عمي مريض سكر كمان لا عنده دواء
بالليل دوا ايش بدنا نشربه لا في صيدليات
فاتحه
اضافه للاطفال الصغار هناك مسن مريض بداء
السكري ويحتاج لعلاج فوري
بالنسبه للدوله مع مال حسين امنه المشفى
زحمه كثير زحمه يعني واحد بخجل منشوف
حالات حرجه يطلب علاجها للسكر والله
المدعيوني ان الاولاد مسهل برد برد كثير
برد يعني بالليل بوز بوز ميكن بوز بالليل
الولاد هيبتنا اكثر لكن نحن بنتحمل شوي بس
الاطفال ما عم تتحمل ولا خرج يتحملوا
ويبقى اقصى ما تعانيه هذه العوائل وجود
اثنين من الاطفال العجز دون رعايه وادويه
لتضاف ماساه جديده الى ماس ليس اقلها غياب
الخيمه زيدان زنجلو العربيه كهرمان مرعش
يقسم العرب النجوم الى قسمين شماليه وتسمى
عند العرب بالشاميه وجنوبيه تسمى باليمنيه
تفاصيل في تقويم دائما مع خالد الزعك
[موسيقى]
تتكون السماء من نجوم ومجرات وكواكب
والعرب قسموا النجوم الى قسمين شماليه
وجنوبيه الشماليه يسمونها بالشاميه
والجنوبيه يسمونها باليابانيه ايا منكحت
ثريا سهيلا عمرك الله كيف يلتقيان هي
شاميه اذا ما اطلت وسهيل اذا اطل يماني
فالشماليه هي الواقعه شمال خط الاستواء
وتدور حول قطبها الشمالي بين قوسين الجدي
والجنوبيه الواقعه شمال خط الاستواء
الجنوبي وتدور حول قطبها الجنوبي بولاريس
استرس وهذه الاقطاب لا تتحرك من مكانها
ليش لانها تقع فوق مركز محور دورانها وين
نجم سهيل يا نجم الجدي همتي ترقى علامتنا
الغمام ما عليه الى طحت من عين الردي
طيحتي من عينه
ارفع للمقام
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
فالكواكب وتعكس ضوء الشمس ساقط على وجهها
والسدم والمجرات تجمعات نجميه والنجوم
تخلق الضوء بذاتها مثل الشمس فالشمس نجم
متواضع تدرون النجم المشتري اكبر من الشمس
بخمس مرات فالشرق نحو الغربي اقرب شقه من
بعد تلك الخمسه الاشبال
الكواكب في علو محلها لترى صغارا وهي غير
صغار
[موسيقى]
الختام بالعناوين
روسيا تعلن تدمير مركز للعمليات تدير دول
غربيه في ليبيض وتجدد التاكيد وفوق
التسويه معي
او المملكه حريصه ايضا
بشكل كبير على
سعوديون في كييف وزير الخارجيه يجدد نهج
السعوديه لحالي الازمه السياسيا وانسانيا
تدخل سوق السعوديه علاج فعال للسكري
وتساؤلات حول اعراضها وعلاقتها بالسمنه
و300 محامي سعودي ينضمون لمبادره المحامي
المجاني خدمه تطوعيه لمستفيد الضمان
الاجتماعي
المره الاولى وزاره الحج والعمره السعوديه
تقيم دوره تدريبيه لتهيئه الحجاج في
بلدانهم
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]